you have to make a decision once and for all that you do not take, I want to think about it.
If you, if I'm selling to you, and you kind of give me some bullshit about you want to think
about it, I'm just going to go ahead and tell you that I've already thought about it for you.
And if, and this is how I phrase it, guys, this is exactly how I do it. I'm not,
I am very blunt, but I say to you this, Mr. Business Owner,
respectfully, because I do enough of these, because I'm literally, we're trying to go across
the nation within, in the best cities possible, it makes zero sense for me. If I let you think
about it, and I let everyone else on my calendar think about it, by Wednesday, I'm going to have
to follow up with 10 people. And all I'm going to do is spend my time following up. And then I got
to hop back on the call with you if you decide to do it. And then we got to go through the onboarding
and the whole deal. So I'm just going to, like a couple of years ago, what I did is I made a
commitment. I do not do, I want to think about it. I have sent you five leads. You have closed
X amount of dollars if they've closed, right? You already are sold on advertising because you
were paying for XYZ service. You already told me you hate that service. You already told me you
want to grow. You know I can bring the heat. You've already seen some of my testimonials.
And I review all the objections I've overcome. If after all of that, because I know that the
last company sure didn't give you free leads, if after all of that, you're not a yes, and it's a
still I want to think about it, this ain't a good fit. This is not a good fit. And I don't want you
to take this wrong. And I'm not trying to burn a bridge. I don't burn a bridge. But this is not a
good fit. I need partners that want to grow. I need partners that are hungry. I need somebody
that wants to go freaking tear someone's throat off and go take over a city and take over a state.
So if this makes sense, let's rock and roll. If it doesn't, then we're not doing the I want
to think about it. You want to do this or not? And then what I'll say is I'll go like,
look, Sam, look, Carl, you and I both know this is the right move. Let's freaking do this deal,
man. Amex or Visa. Let me take the card. Grab my pen. Boom, baby. Right back for the close.